- Le gel désinfectant dans
les lieux publics est-il moins
systématiquement utilisé?
- En général, quand je fais
legagagasins, je le fais dans
ma première boutique et après,
les boutiques d'après...
Les mains, elles en ont marre
quoi.
- En entrant au magasin,
je me désinfecte parce qu'on
touche à tout, puis tout ça.
Ça fait que je préfère
me désinfecter les mains.
- Je le fais quand c'est devant
moi et qu'il y a la pancarte
avec marqué "obligatoire"
elle est devant. Sinon,
je ne le fais pas vraiment.
- De leur côté, certains
commerçants constatent encore
une bonne utilisation
du produit.
C C CATALANO, propriétaire,
boutique Le Trunksho
- Honnêtement, c'est au choix,
mais je vois que 8 de 10 clients
vont l'utiliser encore
aujourd'hui.
BLANDINE MILLE, copropriétaire,
épicerie LOCO Plateau
- Au tout début, on faisait très
très attention, on était très
vigilants. Là, on l'est un petit
peu moins. Mais quêêêême,
ouais. Je dirais bien le deux
tiers des personnes. On voit
avec les bidons que la quantité
diminue, donc ça continue à être
utilisé quand même.
- L'INSPQ recommande toujours
le lavage des mains à l'eau
et au savon. Mais pour ce qui
est du gel désinfectant,
son utilité est questionna
Dr STÉPHANE PERRON, médecin-
conseil, Institut national de
santé publique du QuébecQ)Q)Q)Q)
- Dans le contexte actuel,
ce sera au gouvernement de
décider s'il continue ou pas à
recommander le gel désinfectant,
mais pour ce qui est
de la transmissi
la COVID-19, c'est probablement
pas ça qui va changer
grand chose.
- La COVID-19 se propage
principalement par goutt
très peu de chance de l'attraper
en touchant des objets
dans un commerce.
Quant à l'utilisation
du plexiglas, selon plusieurs
virologues, son utilisation doit
être faite au cas par cas.
Par exemple, il est recommandéee
des patients, parfois malades,
interagissent avec les employés.
L'important, c'est qu'il soit
bien insananananans une salle
ventilée.
Dr HUGUES LOEMBA, professeur
agrégé, Faculté de médecine
Université d'Ottawa
- Le plexiglas peut au moins
empêcher que vous avez un flot
direct de particules virales
qui sont dans l'air et
que vous pouvez ingérer.
- L'utilisation du gel
désinfectant demeure un bon
réflexe, bien que ces effets
pour freiner la propagation
de la COVID-19 demeurent
négligeable, contrairement
au port du masque
Ici Marie Isabelle Rochon,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.